manchmal damals lukas liebe freunde ich
darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen heißt einer neuen episode auf
cd die ganz kurze frage zu beginn wo
gibt es eigentlich dieses t-shirt - oft
stürzen wir uns nun ja allerdings reinen
augen wie meine lieben freunde und der
aufmerksame zuschauer wird schon
erkennen mensch hat es ja amerika
ja
wir sind hört im ausland unterwegs
[Musik]
mm
vernünftige leute unterwegs sein
[Musik]
also entweder zeigen ihre lippen oder
haben kein internet oder es gibt mich
direkt weg wobei ich freundlich hell
bent sage ich sage euch beim nächsten
mal glück
[Musik]
erst wieder ein durcheinander hier
hallo es geht
herzliches deutsch hallo leute ich mich
wie man hört mich nicht
[Musik]
ja ich bin echt aber ich bin in amerika
unterwegs wartet kurz mitte bedeutet
meine freundin marleen diese punkte
allein auf den star lee hatte kurz nach
zehn stunden später wieder vorgetragen
geschafft habt einfach nicht machbar
warte in der machart eicma 2 x 32 x 3 da
jetzt halt wirklich 3 ich will
eigentlich mit amerikanern gerade
sprechen ich bin amerikaner dann rät
englisch mit mir
sie kennen das german english wollten
wir doch sogar die folgte ja sagt die
sagt didi kennt mich nicht
hier zeigt mal 3
so nicht so geht es nämlich nicht
der ist durch
gleich ist der fonds können die küssen
ich will mit leuten aus amerika sprechen
das gibt es besser
mm
vielleicht sollten wir mal ein komplett
anderes land gehen
kasachstan
[Musik]
mm de france
hey
st
herzog
so wie ganz so wie man ein dating leben
die gehen jetzt auf amerika und finden
nette leute
[Musik]
nein bin ich wieder mit dem deutsches
verbunden
stockstadt ii sa mann ich will mehr ich
möchte ich bin ich hab' ich habe
sprachen lernen da denn ich habe amerika
ausgewählt als landes und wollte mit
englischen menschen reden und jetzt komm
ich ihn nur in den nach deutschland
immer ist der echte meso ich habe auch
gefühle und wir gehen jetzt zurück nach
amerika
den hatten wir zu beginn schon
[Musik]
jetzt einmal einmal ein gespräch
aufbauen so von mensch zu mensch einfach
mensch sein den rand der auch
nordamerika wo fünf einwohner ganz kurz
habt ihr als ort deutschland angegeben
ja ja ja ich habe als ort ich war
zwischenzeitlich war ich in kasachstan
aber auch deutsche auch bewusst oder so
immer nur deutschen ja schlimm oder in
england ich will ein zwei amerikaner
[Musik]
ich gucke mir das in den videos ein
worden und ich bin schon immer so dass
ich auf kommen und jetzt da wollte
irgendwann grüßen miguel wir grüßen
gelbe wissen geld und ich gelb uploader
jano immer mit der ruhe
der sinn meines videos heute ist es
eigentlich international neue leute kind
kann das hat bisher nur geklappt
[Musik]
ich will jeden richtigen kumpel treffen
in richtigen freund fürs leben
die nächste person jetzt kommt die erste
person
das wird wenn bester freund fürs leben
an der stelle der heutigen die videos
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
einen daumen hoch und einem video da was
soll ich in meinem nächsten oben die
video machen schreibt sie wohnen in die
kommentare und dennoch keine lose seiten
abonniert main kanal
es ist kostenlos eine verpasst keine
videos mehr und eigentlich will man das
nicht machen
[Musik]